even though Victorious got cancelled
after three seasons it's still hard to
believe the series ended the show's
skyrocketed ariana grande to stardom and
became one of the most popular shows on
nickelodeon at the time but have you
ever noticed just how many innuendos it
has there's even an episode where the
characters have an obsession with feet
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and give this video a big thumbs up if
you still watch victorious now let's
check out ten funny little jokes and
victorious you might have missed
adolescent joke Nickelodeon is known to
never really hold back when it comes to
teenage jokes that will probably go over
a teenager's head but if Yuri watched
some of these as an adult you might
appreciate some of these jokes a lot
better in the first episode of season 3
also known as the holiday special
episode Andre got upset for receiving
his first failing grade ever he gets
angry and asks how it's possible for a
person to go from an a to a D Jade whose
mine seemed to be far away from grades
it replies by saying that this happened
to her in the 8th grade did you catch
the joke while Andre is definitely
talking about failing the class Jade is
actually talking about puberty and her
going from an A cup to a D cup if you
watched this as a kid you probably just
thought she was talking about failing
grades in the 8th grade but it turns out
Jade's joke is much heavier with an
innuendo only older people would
understand and in earlier take of the
same classroom scene we see Andre losing
his cool and pushing Robbie off the
chair we've been here Jade's hilarious
comment that she vets that jingle drop
ease bells any windows never end when
you're on the Nickelodeon show and we
have all these funny jokes to prove it
hey guys please check out the most
awesome sisters on YouTube sister fun
watch can play the latest games go on
amazing adventures and just doing all
sorts of fun and silly things if you
have kids
little brothers or sisters or if you
just want to join in on the family fun
please subscribe to their Channel
that's not my head you have to admit
that Nickelodeon sometimes takes it just
a little bit too far with their adult
jokes we totally understand putting a
few innuendos in the script here and
there but almost every episode in
Victorious has a joke that kids will
never understand let's go back to the
pilot where we slowly get to know Tori
Vega and the rest of the Hollywood Arts
High School gang when it comes to the
talent show scene we see a teacher
telling a student to put the microphone
on Tori's head but we then hear Tori
complaining that the person didn't put
the microphone on her head and hinting
they put it somewhere else we'd like to
keep our channel kid-friendly so we
won't tell you where Nickelodeon thinks
the microphone actually was but you can
probably get the idea the joke was
innocent enough to go over kids heads
but we bet watching it back will make
you go ill in the pilot we also start
getting to know the personalities of the
show's main characters but have you
noticed that Jade's voice and her look
has actually changed since the very
first episode pay attention to the scene
where the students have to improv you'll
see that Jade's character and her strong
personality developed more as the show
went on I'm a thorough player if you're
still with us let us know by writing
team victorious in the comment section
in the third episode of season one we
get to learn more about Tori's talents
Tori is becoming more and more
frustrated that she has to carry around
and play a horn when she'd much rather
sing in user voice simple writes we all
have different talents and it's
important to try things out when you're
a kid so an Andre and cat fine Tori
being all frustrated she admits that
she's not an instrument player in her
words she says that her throat is her
instrument and she's a throat player
instead Andre says that it doesn't count
and Kat adds that it sounds kind of
gross you wouldn't think much of this
joke as a child but I'm sure there are
many adults out there who know why
throat playing just isn't something that
should ever be said in a show like
victorious being a throw player
definitely sounds gross and way too
inappropriate for a kids TV show we're
telling you Nickelodeon has absolutely
no filter even though it would
definitely be useful to turn it on at
least once in a while let's just hope
being a thorough player doesn't put a
lot of pressure on your throats do you
have a credit card this is probably one
of the most innocent jokes on the show
but
but there are a lot of adults who have
experienced real life people that behave
this way kids love to ask for money
right at the seventh episode of season
one featured a scene with Kat and Simeon
and it feels like an introduction to
Kanye West's gold-digger song Kat is
excited over the sky store catalog she
got on an airplane he becomes completely
obsessed and buy tons of ridiculous
stuff until back ends up ripping the
catalog to stop her toward the end of
the episode Patton notices Sinjin and
innocently asks him if he has a
girlfriend Cindy says no and then Kat
asks if he has a credit card to which he
replies with oh yes Kat then suddenly
becomes totally interested in him and
ends up seductively stroking his arm and
telling him to call her sometime how
does Kanye West's song go again we can
definitely find those lyrics and cat's
behavior
we just hope this was just an
inappropriate joke and Kat didn't really
do anything with Sinjin just so she
could get money from him we all know
ariana grande loves to sing about
embracing the sensual side of being a
woman but we do hope that nickelodeon
knows these characters are too young to
do any love related favors to their
friends in exchange for money
Sen Jen vs. Jade teenagers are reckless
especially when we like someone the
Victoria's had a scene that made Sinjin
look well just a little bit creepy
remember the ninth episode of the first
season called the Wi-Fi in the sky Tori
starts to video chat with Andre Kat and
begs to get started on the group
assignment they have to do after a while
Simeon appears and this is when things
get a bit weird as Jade realizes that
the lamp and the sofa on the screen
actually belonged to her house she
freaks out we all know Jade is Cindy's
love interest but this relationship or
better yet an obsession is just
one-sided as soon as Sinjin gets Scott
he leaves with his laptop and tells the
game to not tell his mom it's bizarre
that Sinjin was in Jade's house in the
first place but it's even more bizarre
that he's totally aware he's doing
something wrong and he still doesn't
this probably seems like a funny joke to
all kids but there's just something
extremely creepy about Simon's obsession
with Jade in the same episode received
back to babysitting a dog for a
cheerleader Jade immediately asks why is
Baek doing favors for a cheerleader and
what is that cheerleader doing for him
this probably didn't mean much to you
when you were a kid but we all know what
kind of favors some of the cheerleaders
like to do to the boys they like Tori
vs. Sinjin Sinden is definitely one of
those characters
seems to have way too many inappropriate
lines but as a child you probably never
noticed some of the things that came out
of his mouth or other areas for that
matter in the eleventh episode of the
series Tori pulls Sinjin in a janitor's
closet and asks him to create something
so she'll be able to spy on her friends
while she's explaining the secret plan
sinden keeps imagining she'll kiss him
because that's what happens in his dream
whenever she pulls him in the janitor's
closet
Tori ignores Syngenta creepy behavior
and keeps on asking him for help until
he agrees when he says yes she gives him
a kiss on the cheek completely shocked
Sinjin watches her leave the closet and
says he's experiencing the same feeling
he already felt before
Tori comes back to tell him she heard
that and leaves again something tells us
cuttance engines dreams Tori is doing
something more than just kissing him to
make that certain feeling come to Sinjin
the more we talk about Sinjin the more
we feel like his stories are all just a
big inappropriate joke
sure teenage boys will do anything to
get a kiss from the girl they like but
what Sinjin is doing is just a bit TMI
slapped with a sausage
if you thought inappropriate jokes ever
end in Victorious you're wrong even
though the show officially ended you can
find more and more adult jokes as yury
watch the episodes in the twelfth
episode called
cat's new boyfriend things just get
really weird we see the students
partying at the kickback and the running
joke of the night is the mysterious
sausages they are eating because sicko
it's the acting teacher who won't tell
them what meat they're made of that
alone should raise a few eyebrows but it
even gets otter we see Tori watching cat
and Danny dancing Jayden asks her if
Danny ever spun her like that instead of
replying Tori aggressively asks if Jade
would like to be slapped by a sausage
any normal reaction would be saying no
but for some strange reason Jay says yes
Tori obviously refuses but why on earth
would Jade even say yes in the first
place is Nickelodeon implying that Jade
is familiar with this sort of thing
let's just stop right here before things
get any more gross
shall we we can probably get an idea why
Jade would say yes to getting a
mysterious sausage in her face it's far
too inappropriate to even discuss we're
telling you Nickelodeon didn't hold back
when it came to adult jokes on this show
you don't know what I've got the
characters on this show already have big
personalities but things can get pretty
bizarre when they get involved with
other
things like dummies for example we all
know Robbie has a dummy but do you
remember the scene from the second
episode where we learned far too many
things about his puppet Rex in this
particular scene Tori flirts with Robbie
Robbie has a massive crush on her
anyways but he's too shy to do anything
about it
he escapes tori by giving the excuse
that Rex has to use the bathroom
pretty clever right well Tori doesn't
let him off the hook that easily if you
think about it a dummy doesn't really
have to use the bathroom
so it's clear Robbie's just avoiding her
after Rex claims that he has to be taken
to the bathroom because he has to pee
now Tory gets visibly frustrated as she
watches them leave
she then shouts that he's a puppet and
he can't even pee and Rex well it's
actually Robbie if you think about it
replies that she doesn't even know what
he is considering they're talking about
a bathroom ordeal it's safe to say rex
is talking about body parts implying he
definitely has something you can use to
go to the bathroom it's even odder once
you realize all of this is being said by
Robbie who manages to be totally
inappropriate despite having a crush on
Tori just the girls teenage boys are
highly inappropriate and we totally
understand why if you've been around
boys while in school you know the jokes
can sometimes go just a little bit too
far but it seems like boys and TV shows
like victorious take their creepiness
and obsession with girls to a new level
that shouldn't even exist Nickelodeon
gave a sad impression from the very
first victorious episode we ever saw in
the first episode Tori's getting ready
for her performance she has to change
and she needs help everyone seems to go
behind the scenes to help her change and
we mean absolutely everyone the guys
only seem to stop when it's pointed out
that it's just the girls that should
help her change her clothes seems
understandable right well it's not
according to Nickelodeon well this is
clearly a funny joke and a comical break
from the showcase nervousness it really
portrays teenage boys in the most
stereotypical way ever
why else would teenage boys want to go
behind the scenes to help Tori change
her clothes if you think about it the
whole situation is kind of gross and
we're just glad they were told that they
are definitely not allowed to go back
there did you catch this joke the first
time around leave us a comment and tell
us what you thought Puka fish
everyone wants soft feet right the
nickelodeon took it a little bit too far
with the soft feet fascination in the
12th episode of the first season sweet
told you this episode is just weird the
episode called cats new boyfriend has
way too many inappropriate scenes and we
bet there are even more of them out
there have you ever noticed how this
whole episode is just about a foot
fetish would you ever really touch
someone's foot at a party it seems to
have been the storyline for this episode
Treena used
Puka fish to make her feet smooth these
fish are known to eat dead skin and
leave you with the softest speed ever
this didn't seem to work on anyone else
because trina actually bought those fish
from a dodgy guy in a van but have you
noticed that even the doctor even though
he was angry about it still admired
Trina's soft feet not to mention Jay -
Trina if the fish are actually painful
and when Trina said no Jade was visibly
disappointed Jade seems to have a thing
for the pain and when you combine that
with her being okay with getting slapped
by a sausage it just gets a bit weird
seriously how many innuendos are you
able to find in a single victorious
episode
[Music]
[Music]
told you not to tell anyone you did not
make that clear what are you up to these
days
Tori Vega after graduating from
Hollywood Arts High School what did you
go on to do we really miss all the
shenanigans you got up to on Victorious
we miss watching you and Andre get into
all sorts of trouble we wonder what
happened to BEC and Jade are they still
together we never get tired or free
watching the show but there are some
huge plot holes we missed the first time
around
Nickelodeon's victorious was one amazing
show but it is sports season run there
are a lot of plot holes mistakes and
inconsistencies keep watching for the
most shocking plot holes from the hit
series Rex's bighead Oh Rex Rex was one
of our favorite characters from
Victorious and he wasn't exactly human
okay he wasn't human at all Rex was a
puppet Robbie Shapiro was such an
awkward character in a lot of ways and
his artistic talent that landed him a
spot of Hollywood Arts High School was
ventriloquist
he was a puppet master and Rex was his
prophet it was pretty hilarious the way
Ronnie treated Rex like a real person it
was even better when all the other
characters treated him like he was a
part of the gang but there's a big
problem with Rex in the pilot episode
Rex has a huge head but in later
episodes his head is a lot smaller what
happened is the Rex we've come to know
and love actually Rex 2.0 is it the same
puppet with a new head
maybe the show's creators just hoped we
wouldn't notice we have to wonder what
happened to the original Rex we aren't
sure why they felt the need to change
him and we definitely want an
explanation Drake and Josh
sometimes shows exists within the same
universe and this is very common on
Disney Channel and Nickelodeon shows
characters will cross over with other
series victorious was created by the
same guy who invented Drake and Josh
Dan Schneider created what a lot of fans
call Schneider versts but here's the
thing it's not exactly clear how Drake
and Josh
exists in the victorious universe there
were several times that they discussed
Drake and Josh as if it is a TV show
tori and training
it happened on a TV show that would mean
victorious takes place in our world but
then there's Helen Helen takes over as
principal of Hollywood Arts High School
and she is playing the exact same
character as she does on Drake and Josh
what does this mean is it an
inconsistency between episodes
maybe Drake and Josh is supposed to be a
reality show in the victorious universe
that would be super cool
can you imagine Drake and Josh as
reality stars or maybe Dan Schneider
wants us to be confused we just don't
know what to think but this pothole has
a scratching our heads Tory gets stuck
Tory gets stuck was one of the wildest
episodes of Victorious Ravi is
hospitalized because a toy car is stuck
in his intestines
Jane has gone to extreme lengths to keep
Tory from being in the play including
reading Tory's medical file
Tory agrees to have surgery and donate
blood to Ravi that's a huge pothole in
itself it's not exactly clear why Tory
needs to have a whole surgery just to
donate blood and why doesn't the
hospital have Robbie's blood type in
reserve
they say it's rare but it's own egative
which isn't the most common blood type
in this episode Tory also gets stuck at
no Zoo she and Robbie need to cough up
22 dollars before they can leave she
tweets that she is using the restaurants
computer but why doesn't she use the
computer or the restaurants phone to
contact someone she could ask them to
bring her the money that seems like an
easy fix to us this episode left us with
so many questions also Jade basically
tried to poison Tory by sending her
flowers she's allergic to that is pretty
extreme the other classes Tori and the
rest of the gang attend Hollywood Arts
High School it's a special arts high
school for talented teenagers they have
all sorts of programs for artistic
teenagers there's music drama dancing
and ventriloquist missing you might not
have even noticed it we certainly missed
it the first time around but if you go
back and re-watch the series pay
attention to their classes they only
ever seem to go to art classes they even
take multiple acting classes and other
creative courses but this is still a
high school why aren't they taking math
where are their English and history
classes there are plenty of real art
schools in the you
States but the students still take
normal classes like algebra and
government does it seem odd that they
never study anything normal that can't
be a great way to prepare them for the
real world also we would have loved to
see them in regular classes
can you imagine Rex and Robbie taking
literature what about cat trying to
learn calculus it would have been so
funny Tori's Locker one of the biggest
mistakes in Victorious happened in
season one and honestly we aren't sure
how the set designers and directors
missed it in the great ping-pong scam
Tori learns that there is a ping-pong
team and she quickly finds out that they
aren't a real team but a flashback shows
that two years before Andre back cat
Jade and Robbie finds a ping-pong table
they really want to go to a fancy dinner
at an expensive restaurant called
maestro's so they devised a plan to form
a team to get the $1,500 the school
gives to the sports teams sicko it's
agrees to sponsor them when they tell
them that the principal could get fired
if they don't get a big trophy then they
go to dinner at maestro's to buy a
trophy it's completely ridiculous and
hilarious and here's the thing in a
flashback we can see Tori's signature
make it shine on her locker in the
background but this supposedly happened
two years before she got there how is
her locker there hey victorious fans do
you love watching videos about all your
favorite TV shows then you'll love the
things click that big red subscribe
button and turn on notifications to
never miss another video if you're
watching on your phone make sure your
notifications are turned on for YouTube
[Music]
terrible teacher
that last blooper leads us to our next
plot hole Oh sicko it's he was such a
strange character he does a lot of weird
things like climbing in the window to
his classroom and drinking from a
coconut I'm gonna drink its milk the
students like him but he's honestly a
terrible teacher and that's the bottle
how did such a prestigious school like
Hollywood arts allow such a terrible
teacher to work there his lessons are
total nonsense he teaches them things
like improv is like a fine cheese but
not really he always wants to be the
center of attention he helped the
student scam this
out of $1,500 feel out Jada pour coffee
on Tori and class
he throws a ball at a student's to get
their attention that sort of behavior
should make a teacher lose their license
it really makes no sense that this guy
is an authority figure are you loving
these potholes and mistakes keep
watching to find out which Victoria's
photo left us dazed and confused
Trina's admission for Trina she really
gets a lot of flack over the course of
the show she gets made fun of a lot and
some of it is really mean remember the
time Jade posted a video of Trina
getting hurt online so everyone would
laugh we know Trina can be really
spoiled and annoying but her character
goes through a lot the whole premise for
Tori getting into Hollywood arts is that
she takes Trina's place in a singing
showcase Trina can't sing at all her
lack of talent is always gossip devout
and made fun of but somehow she still
manages to get into Hollywood arts
okay we know mr. suka wits isn't quite
in his right mind during her audition
but at some point pretty soon after the
school would figure out that she's not
artistically inclined she might have
some other talents but the show doesn't
address them it just focuses on how
untalented she is it's fine that she
doesn't have
artsy skills but she certainly doesn't
belong at an art school prom problem we
understand that sometimes TV
inconsistencies happen from episode to
episode it's hard to keep up with
everything that characters say
especially when there are a lot of
episodes this sort of thing happens a
lot on Victorious one in particular
happens in season two
Tori convinces the others to have a prom
and through the whole episode the
students swear they've never had a prom
in Hollywood Arts and they don't really
want a normal prom dance but when we
went back and re-watch the pilot episode
we noticed something weird sicko its
tells Kat to tell the others to come
back to the classroom she runs out and
tells Andre Robby and the rest of the
crew what sikka was once Rex responds if
they never had a prom
how does that make any sense maybe Rex
was just being mean even if it wasn't
true but it's definitely a strange thing
to joke about what happened to Kat one
time victorious made something major
happen to a character and then they
never resolved the storyline in Rex ties
the main storyline was about
Rex getting sucked into the turbojet
Tory convinces a doctor at the hospital
to treat Rex even though he's just a
puppet then she turns the heart monitor
back on after the puppet flatlines but
while they were at the hospital
something happens to cap she goes to
talk to the receptionist after Jay tells
her two fat cats a little weird and the
receptionist thinks she belongs to the
psychiatric ward the doctor even says
that they should call in a specialist
after cat scratches her nose with her
feet but the episode just ends with Kat
locked away in a padded room none of her
friends go to find her and the episode
never explains what happens they just
left her there it would have been nice
and probably hilarious to see Kats
storyline get resolved the smooch this
final plot hole actually happened years
after victorious ended even yogya who
plays back transparent likes to post
throwback pictures on his social media
Sansa victorious loved these reminders
from the show but in 2017 he posted
something weird it's a picture where
back is laying on Jade's lap and Tory is
about to give him a smooch this photo
looks super intimate but fans cannot
figure out where this photo is from Jade
would never have just sat there while
Tory made a move on back and we also
have no memory of this happening there
is a clip of a similar scene in the
opening credits but Tory definitely
isn't close to beckon it was this
picture photoshopped
if so someone did a great job but why
would even post it on his Instagram
maybe this is something that happens
behind the scenes but that doesn't
explain why it happened it could be a
scene that was cut from the final
version like a dream sequence
either way this weird photo definitely
made Torian Beck shippers happy that's a
wrap what was your favorite victorious
moment let us know in the comments
section
[Music]
I'm the main event don't turn lips no
think about it Rob - jeez dad I buy you
a lot of body wash victorious was one of
the most popular Nickelodeon shows for
teenagers and many fans still can't
understand why it ended so quickly
without even getting a final episode
there are many mysteries surrounding the
show and today will tell them all join
us as we expose Jory look at music sales
charts talk about scandals and find out
what the parents actually thought of the
show if you're new here hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video and don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up now let's expose some of the
darkest secrets Victorious tried to hide
ariana grande and victoria justice so
let's start by getting the cat out of
the bag not literally we're sure Cat
Valentine was never in a bag anyways
it's no secret that over the years more
and more stories came out that ariana
grande and Victoria Justice just didn't
get along from shading each other to
Ariana saying she worked with someone
who told her they'd never liked her and
that she got bullied later
Victoria cleared out those groomers by
saying ariana was talking about someone
she worked on a show called Broadway
Victoria also became a huge mean after
she said that the entire cast could sing
when Ariana was singled out as a
talented singer she quickly got branded
as petty and remains one of the reasons
why the show potentially ended hey guys
we are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup acts and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us
affection he left me here pin you see
you there
it was victorious fault so let's look at
some of the secrets Victoria Justice had
more closely in 2015 there seemed to
have been even more rumors floating
around that the show getting canceled
was entirely Victoria's fault the rumor
that Victoria was going to do a solo
tour instead of the cast tour made the
fans think she was leaving her
co-workers behind to start her own music
career
it doesn't help her case that ariana
held a victorious reunion in 2016
without Victoria Victoria addressed the
rumors and stated she had nothing to do
with the cancellation of the show do you
think she's telling the truth
jealousy from the cast some say that the
cast were all so jealous of Ariana's
immediate success if you look at the
first season of Victoria's you might
find that the profiles of the two
singers were relatively similar
everything was fine until ariana was
cast on a Victoria spin-off show and
started receiving more limelight than
any other cast the success of her song
the way was likely a result of her
success on Victorious and even though
she wasn't a lead character on the show
Victoria song gold didn't have the same
charting success as grande was starting
to bring more and more money into her
project it made Victoria jealous this
could also be the reason behind her
petty I think we can all say in comment
Victoria Justice pictures leaked did you
know that Victoria justices private
photos leaked online back in 2014 by the
time it happened the show was already
cancelled but even though Victoria
denied these were her photos at first
she later admitted they belong to her no
one wants to have their private photos
leaked especially not if you're an
underage Nickelodeon star although the
scandal became international news it got
quickly forgotten as Victoria took legal
actions against the hackers who exposed
her privacy although it's highly
unlikely this had anything to do with
Victorious it probably did affect
Nickelodeon's image and their
professional relationship with Victoria
for any future work
we're Elizabeth and Victoria dating a
tumblr blog called TV cancellation
theories comes up with a lot of
potential secrets shows like Victoria's
tried to hide and what resulted in them
being cancelled keep in mind that this
is just a theory and it should
definitely be taken with a grain of salt
if you loved Tori Vega and Jade West you
were most likely a jewelry shipper who
desperately wanted the two characters to
be together fans still speculate that
the two were actually in a relationship
and Nickelodeon didn't approve in 2016
Victoria and Elizabeth had a victorious
reunion all by themselves and they
proved that Jory is definitely still
alive do you think they're more than
just cast mates and friends problematic
Ariana we've already talked about how
the cast especially Victoria were most
likely jealous of Ariana Grande the
media success but Ariana's beginnings
were extremely problematic for a
Nickelodeon star it seems that Ariana
was not only potentially feuding with
Victoria but there also seems to be a
salmon cat cast member who really didn't
like working with the famous singer
we all remember Ariana's donut licking
incident from her early days but it
looks like the star might have been
pretty problematic on set
although jennette mccurdy stated that
her and Ariana butted heads in a very
sisterly way she posted a tweet about an
anonymous person and said that every
time they hung out she was in a
quicksand because she was getting
completely lost in her world who do you
think this was actually about the
creator wanted it to continue it's still
unclear why the show canceled in the
first place but from what it seems like
everyone really wanted to Toria Stu
continued even the show's creator Dan
Schneider took it to Twitter to address
some of the show's rumors he stated that
he would love to have made more than 60
victorious episodes and that he knows
some of the fans are upset and angry
then he said that the fans shouldn't be
upset with Victoria Leon Liz Ariana Ava
nor any other members of the cast as
they all wanted the show to continue it
really seems that Nickelodeon put their
foot down when it came to canceling the
show even though nobody wanted it to
happen but why they really didn't want
it to end
even though it seems like Victoria is
blamed for the cancellation of the show
it looks like she really didn't want it
to end
in fact she took it to Twitter and wrote
a very lengthy letter on why she's
grateful for victorious she even wrote
her very own ending since the show never
got a season finale
according to Victoria Tori gets a record
deal and becomes a pop star Andrey is
also a pop star as well as a writer and
producer
Terina gets accepted to the new season
of The Bachelor Beck gets cast in his
own series and Kat marries Robbie and
starts her own babysitting service with
Sam make sure to let us know your own
version of Victorious very final episode
in the comments their music was
successful here's another possible
theory why Victoria has got the
unexpected boot unlike movies like High
School Musical and shows like Glee the
crisps just didn't feature charting
music that would make up for the
production costs even though the show
had 2 million average viewers and was
one of the most popular team shows on
Nickelodeon the sales of the cast music
didn't produce the same results the
victorious soundtrack debuted on the
Billboard 200 at number 5 and sold
40,000 copies meanwhile Ariana's debut
song sold 2.3 million copies as of March
2016
since nickelodeon seemed to only focus
on ariana grande success it could be the
victorious average sales just weren't
enough to continue with the show parents
hated the show and lastly the show
didn't seem to have much support from
the parents
even though their kids loved the show
the parents just didn't seem to get on
board with many things including
victorious as inappropriate jokes the
parents have criticized rude characters
who seem to have absolutely no manners
according to them the show also features
a lot of pushover parents who seem to
have no control over their kids lives
and create a false reality of how a
teenager is supposed to act in the real
world
some even criticize that the show
focuses way too much on girls being
liked by boys and doesn't bring enough
diversity to be an educational
Nickelodeon show could this be why
Nickelodeon finally decided to pull the
plug on Victorious let us know what
secrets we should expose next
[Music]
you Rex you're nothing like your best
friend Robbie he's shy and more than a
little awkward but you you say
whatever's on your mind you have no
filter and you aren't afraid to flirt
with girls but the biggest difference
between you and Robbie is that your head
drastically shrunk in size whereas
Robbie's well Robbie's pretty much
stayed the same throughout the series
so we hate to ask but are you the same
puppet we saw in the pilot episode
because it really doesn't look like it
wrecks power spontaneous face change
isn't the only mistake fans noticed in
victorious in fact this show has tons of
unforeseen goofs from plot holes to
continuity errors to audio problems but
even then victorious is still one of the
best TV shows ever proving that nothing
not even victorious is perfect keep
watching to find out about the hilarious
hair nut goof we spotted in the episode
how Trina got in a lot of goofs happen
in the one-hour special titled Tori goes
platinum this is a really fun episode
because we get to see Tori sporting a
bunch of new looks
Tori wins a contest and lands herself a
gig at the Platinum Music Awards Tori
Vega how would you like to sing the
opening number this is music applause
but Jade metals and manages to snatch
tours role away from her to cheer Tori
up Andre Robbie and back go to Tori's
house and give her a chocolate leaf
blower but when Tori tells Robbie and
Andre that they can go to the awards
they run out of her place and Robbie
steals the gift they brought her in the
next shot however is the blue and pink
gift bag is still on the floor there's
another continuity error in the episode
- earlier in the series it was revealed
that Tori couldn't play in the
instruments as mentioned in episodes
like stage fighting and a Becks big
break but in Tori's audition tape we see
her playing the piano like a pro while
she could have learned how to play on
her own
she was playing in an unusually skilled
banner for
in ER no I did Jade West isn't the
easiest person to get along with she's
opinionated sarcastic and quite frankly
she can be a little mean and scary but
that's not to say that there isn't a
nice person beneath that stone-cold
exterior in the episode titled the wood
a reality TV show called the wood is
filmed at Hollywood Arts the students
step in front of the camera to tell the
show's executives a little bit about
themselves and one of the producers
asked Jade's name a few things that she
doesn't like Jade goes on a hey Trent
and the first thing she says tuna fish
we wouldn't call Jade a liar but we know
for a fact that Jade quite likes it so
much so that she's eaten tuna fish
sandwiches for lunch before in the
episode titled robber Ozzy Robbie starts
spying on his fellow classmates and
posting some very embarrassing videos of
them online he posts a video of Baek and
Jade talking in a car and it's here that
Jade states that she ate tuna fish for
lunch
while it isn't the biggest continuity
error it does make Jade look a little
shady we mean why would she lie about
hating tuna fish on camera challenge but
plot holes and continuity errors aren't
the only things that made it into
victorious the show also had a handful
of audio problems when it came to
syncing voiceovers to their videos
turns out the episode titled robber Ozzy
had more goofs than one in this episode
Robbie's minions managed to snap
pictures of Tori after she's applied
armpit cream to her underarms Robbie
uploads the pictures to his blog but
seconds later we can see that Robbie's
lips don't match up with the audio it's
completely off but this wouldn't be the
first time Robbie's character
experienced audio problems and it
wouldn't be the last time either in the
episode titled of Tori the zombie we see
this happen yet again while Tori Beck
and Robbie are singing on stage Tory
hits Robbie and he says ow
but his lips are offbeat it's normal for
actors to record songs in the studio and
later act out the scenes while
lip-syncing but these two audio mishaps
were way off
which is why viewers noticed them in the
first place you ready I think the real
question is are you ready
one of the funniest episodes in
victorious history is none other than
survival of the hottest during this
episode the Los Angeles area is hit with
a heat wave so the students decide to
take a well-deserved a mini road trip to
Venice Beach this episode has two
continuity errors and one major plot
hole the first error happens when Beck
and Jade get to the RV seconds before
Kat rushes out to use the bathroom keep
a close eye on Jade sunglasses they
disappear and reappear between takes a
handful of times then once in the RV the
gang finds out that they're locked in
their only option is to wait for Kat to
come back from the bathroom
leading Jade to plop down on the couch
in the back of the RV but when the
camera switches over to Tori we can see
Jade sitting back down on the sofa but
the episodes biggest plot hole revolves
around the heat wave itself the gang was
stuck in the scorching RV without proper
ventilation for hours on end in real
life this would have stopped them from
fighting singing and talking because
well they would have been much too weak
to do anything at all give this video a
big thumbs up if you're enjoying it so
far and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more fun videos we post
weekly videos about all your favorite
Nickelodeon shows so be sure to go into
your YouTube settings and switch on
notifications to get notified as soon as
we upload something new there are so
many things wrong with the episode
titled brain squeezers we don't even
know where to begin it all starts when
the gang is selected to appear on the
game show brain squeezers they pick
teams and get ready to battle it out on
camera but there's something seriously
wrong with the host of the show and the
show itself first of all all the
contestants are miners and you can't
appear on TV without a legal guardian
signature secondly the show is so
violent it's a wonder that none of the
students were sent to the hospital we
mean come on can't received a full-on
blow to the face the force the impact
was so strong it should have broken her
nose at the very least and then a car
batteries dropped on Jade's head for
crying out loud
the entire brain squeezes crew should
have been sent to jail for putting the
lives of miners
risk then when Jade gets her question
wrong they pummel her with salt and
batteries but the blue team's reaction
to Jade's doink was used twice in a
matter of seconds
first when Jade was sprinkled with salt
and once again when the car battery fell
on her head
this next TV mistake is a little more
subtle but that didn't stop diehard
victorious fans from calling it out
online in the pilot episode Andre tries
to convince Tory not to drop out of
Hollywood arts and then Robbie and Rex
informs them that sicka wits wants them
to head back to the classroom
seconds later Kat comes along to remind
the students that their teacher really
wants them to get back to class Rex goes
full savage on cat he mocks her saying
oh the pilot episode pretty much
confirms that Hollywood Arts has hosted
a prom in the past but then in the
episode titled prom wrecker we hear the
students saying the exact opposite of
that Tori even talks to sicka wits and
tells him that Hollywood Arts has never
had a prom before
wait why are we talking about proms in
the opening scene of the episode titled
Tori and Jade's playdate sick of it -
asks Kat Robby to deliver some bad news
and a happy wave now improvise a scene
where you have to give Tanner that bad
news in a way that doesn't upset him so
Robby and captures to tell Tanner the
bad news while singing and playing the
guitar during this scene we can see that
Rex is sitting on a chair in the
background he's facing right throughout
the song but after the bad news has been
delivered Rex is looking the other way
we seriously hope that Rex can't move on
his own because that would be way too
freaky then midway through the episode
sicko wits forces
Tori and Jade to go on a sushi date to
better learn how to play husband and
wife the girls aren't too happy about
this but if you keep an eye on Tori's
glass of green tea throughout the scene
you can see that it mysteriously
disappears and reappears between takes
my date and I were wondering if you have
a flight of stairs we could throw
ourselves down
it's hard to keep track of every little
detail when filming a hectic episode
like the one titled the slap fight so
that must be why there were so many
discrepancies in the game short film
socks and violins in this episode cat on
Drabek Tori Robby and Jade are tasked
with creating a short film for one of
their classes but they're short on time
because of their obsession with social
media 19 hours to finish that short film
the gang manages to create a short film
with minutes to spare
but viewers quickly noticed some
continuity errors in their school
project at the beginning of socks and
violins Jade is wearing an eyepatch over
her right eye but after a few seconds
the eyepatch jumps to her left eye and
then back again it's so easy to spot
that we almost didn't notice what was
happening with Jade's drink at the
beginning of the video she had fruit in
her glass but throughout the short film
the fruits mysteriously disappear and
reappear freak the freak out in the
first part of the episode of freak to
freak out the gang goes to a karaoke bar
and things get a little intense
Haley and Tara flirt with Beck and Andre
when Jade leaves to grab a soda if you
get nervous I'll hold your hands
and Jade loses it on them when she sees
what's going on
Jaden Kat are challenged to a sing-off
and during their performance Jade grabs
the food off Hayley and Tara's plate and
throws it around but during the very
next take we can see that the plate of
food is untouched as if Jade had never
taken her anger out on that poor little
burger in the episode titled how Trina
got in torreón Robbie go to a sushi
restaurant and Robbie offers to pay the
bill because Tori helped him massage his
grandma's feet we know pretty weird
stuff right but problem is Robbie left
his wallet at school so they can't pay
for the food that just ate the
restaurant owner puts them to work
chopping squid and at one point Torian
Robbie ripped their hair nets off in a
fit of rage but in the next shot
Robbie still has his hairnet on although
it disappears a few seconds later and
that's a wrap on the 10 huge mistakes
that made it into victorious before you
go tell us who your favorite character
is in the comments oh and be sure to
tell us which ship you prefer bade or
bori younger older don't say a word
me and Jade's boyfriend isn't always
easy now is it back she's got a big
personality and she isn't afraid to use
it
while some people see her as a fiercely
dark humor person deep down you know she
has a heart of gold Jade would do
anything for you back a little too much
if you ask us but hey we wouldn't want
to get on your girlfriend's bad side
Jade West is a savage and Tori Vega can
attest to that
but despite all of her shortcomings Jade
is hilarious and victorious wouldn't
have been the same without her we've
lined up all of Jade's most savage
moments keep watching to find out which
one of these moments could have landed
Jade in jail
Jade dumps back in season 1 episode 5
Jade decides to break things off with
back when she finds out that she's been
hanging out and texting Alyssa Vaughn
she's super jealous and she doesn't
trust him but even then she wants him
back Tory goes out of her way to help
Jade when her boyfriend back and she
encourages her to do something nice for
him like get him that dog he always
wanted
once they patched things up Tory asks
Jade for a ride home and Jade being the
savage she is tells her that it's not
that far away yep the girl is merciless
Tory and Jade's playdate in season 3
episode 6 Tori and Jade are selected to
play a married couple in a new play
but sicka wits isn't too happy with how
Jade and Tori are getting along so he
forces them to go out on a date during
the state Tori points out that there's
no good reason that they can't sit down
and have a conversation and that's when
Jade strikes
she tells Tori that there's a good
reason and then says I don't like you
ouch that one must have left a mark the
wood in season 1 episode 18 a reality
show called the wood sets up shop at
Hollywood Arts and the students are
interviewed to win a spot on the show
Jade doesn't hold back when the
producers ask her to name some of the
things that she hates she goes off on a
rant saying that she hates things like
flowers giggling rainbows and the color
yellow and most of all jokes man I hate
ducks it's a hilarious moment that
ultimately wins her a spot on the show
opposite date we all know Jade is a
jealous girlfriend but she took things
to a whole new level in season 4 episode
3 in the episode titled opposite date
Kat accidentally tells Jade about how
Beck and Tori are on what they are
calling an opposite date Jade flips out
and proceeds to stock them by
impersonating Kat on the phone it's a
hilarious moment but Jade goes full
savage when she tricks Kat into putting
her head on her shoulder only to
restrain her cover her mouth and steal
her phone the gorilla Club in season 3
episode 4 Jaden Beck get into another
fight Beck points out that he's tired of
all the fighting prompting Jade to ask
him if he wants to break
and that's when trina jumps in and tries
to make a move on [ __ ] j fires back
immediately she throws a pillow at her
face and warns her that next time it's a
hammer helen back again in season 2
episode 8 jade goes ballistic during a
school announcement when Sikowitz is
having a hard time getting the student
boy to listen to his speech jade stands
up and quiets everyone down by screaming
it's a hilarious moment that just goes
to show how intimidating Jade can be
sicko it's fires back by calling Jade
sweet and feminine brain squeezers it's
no secret that jade has a bone to pick
with Tori and this is showcased once
again in season 4 episode 10 when Tori
asks Jade for a fry instead of giving
her one Jade spits all over them and
Tori forgets all about Jade's fries but
sinden doesn't Jade warns him expect
lows but he chooses to eat one anyway
opposite date part two there are a lot
of savage moments in the episode titled
opposite date like the time that Jade
asks Tori if she's wearing a new top and
then says thanks when she says that she
is while Jake can come off as a bully
there's a method to her madness
and besides Tori is no angel the birth
week song in season 1 episode 4 jage
plays a prank on Tori and it's a pretty
gross one she asked story to try our
coffee and tell her what it tastes like
only to laugh and tell her I don't know
I found it in the garbage
then when Trina refers to Jade as Tory's
friend Jade walks off saying that she
isn't her friend who was it just us or
is Jade on a roll
Tory gets stuck this savage Jade moment
should have landed her in jail in season
2 episode 4 Jade gets cast as Tori's
understudy so she plots against her when
Tori donates her blood to save Robbie
Jade gets rid of the first pint forcing
Tori to miss the play here are the
things we post daily videos about
nostalgic shows like victorious so make
sure to subscribe if you're watching on
your mobile go into your YouTube
settings and switch on notifications so
you never miss another video clearly
Jade is one wicked character but we love
her all the same who was your favorite
character from Victorious sound off in
the comments thanks for watching give
this video of
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things will see you
next time